- [Narrator] In 1904, St. Louis
hosted an Olympic marathon
for the ages.
Overshadowed by the
neighboring World's Fair,
the poorly-planned event was reduced
to a lackluster sideshow
primed for disaster.
During a sweltering 90-degree day,
the runners were thrust
onto a hellish route
that cut through car
traffic, rocks, thick dust,
and 300-foot hills.
Of the 32 athletes who competed,
only 14 finished.
And of the 14, these are the
three worth knowing about.
Fred Lorz was a fresh-faced athlete
ready to make a name for himself.
For nine miles, Lorz was
near the front of the pack,
until painful muscle cramps
stopped him in his tracks.
And, he wasn't the only one.
Almost every single racer
had severe muscle cramps
that day, thanks to this dummy.
Chief event organizer
and amateur scientist,
James Sullivan.
You see, Sullivan turned
the event into an experiment
to grasp how purposeful
dehydration affects athletes.
Immune to common sense, Sullivan
put a single water station
at the 11th mile mark.
So, for 26 miles, the runners
relied on one water station
that was dirty.
And gave you dysentery.
James Sullivan, what a guy.
Oops.
Anyway, back to Lorz.
With he sun beating down,
road dust clogging his lungs,
and his muscles spazzing in
protest, Lorz had enough,
and traded in his two
legs for four wheels.
He hitched a car ride
to the 19th mile mark,
got out, and gingerly ran
through the finish line.
The crowd went wild, but
before the gold medal
could be placed around his
neck, his ruse was discovered.
Next up, Andarín Carvajal.
He was a five-foot-tall Cuban national,
and former mailman turned athlete.
To get to St. Louis,
Carvajal had to raise money
by competing in running events,
including a 700-mile race across Cuba.
Once he got to St. Louis,
he was easy to spot.
Among the sleeveless shirts
and thigh-high shorts,
Carvajal wore a billowing,
long-sleeve shirt,
cut-off slacks, and work boots.
He didn't dress like a sports champion,
but damn, did he run like one.
With each and every step,
Carvajal charged towards the finish line.
Even though his legs never gave out,
his grumbling stomach did.
To satisfy his hunger,
he ate some apples from a nearby orchard
that turned out to be rotten.
So he took a little recovery nap,
and then proceeded to
finish in fourth place.
And then, there's Thomas Hicks.
The gold winner.
The top dog.
The champion.
The barely standing living cadaver.
You see, Hicks was so physically ill
that he couldn't cross the finish line
without the help of his trainers.
Why?
Well, back then, stimulants were legal,
and strychnine, a type of rat poison,
was thought to have
performance-enhancing properties.
So during the run, his trainers gave him
small doses to gain an edge.
But instead of helping him,
it was slowly killing him.
Once Hicks was dragged
across the finish line,
he wasn't in a cheery mood.
Having lost eight pounds during the race,
he was a hollowed-out husk of a man.
The judges shrugged and
gave Hicks the gold,
ending the nightmare.
As the crowd swooned over
Hicks's disheveled body,
somewhere in the stands,
James Sullivan was probably
sipping on a glass of fresh water,
feeling proud of putting together
the worst marathon ever.